thank you conference
what a day
it has been tough
but we need to focus on the job in hand
we need to move forward
no more distractions we have a plan and
we need to get on and deliver it that's
what the public that's what the public
expects
that's what the public expects from the
government but first conference welcome
back to Birmingham this is a remarkable
City it has a history of great
Brilliance Joseph Chamberlain in the
19th century was an extraordinary Civic
leader who led Birmingham and the world
through the Industrial Revolution and
today Andy street is following in that
great tradition
graphs and grit turned this small town
first into a thriving industrial market
then into one of the centers of the
Industrial Revolution which powered and
grew not just the British economy but
provided the new technologies that
changed the world forever the Industrial
Revolution was one of the most
Monumental transformations in human
history and it began here with
determination and application those
britons built a thriving economy they
inspire me today they remind us that in
Britain with the British people
absolutely anything is possible
our plan today focuses on the same bold
sentiment the same inspiration to deal
with the challenges of today by giving
people the tools they need to thrive
tomorrow to get Britain moving
we have
we have great ideas we have the same
inspirational people and I know we have
the same determination
our growth plan set out 10 days ago will
ensure we focus relentlessly on economic
growth because we must face up to the
fact that for too long our economy has
not grown enough the path ahead of us
was one of slow managed decline
but I refuse to accept that it is
somehow Britain's Destiny to fall back
into middle League status or that the
tax burden reaching a 17 a 70-year high
is somehow inevitable it isn't and it
shouldn't be
we needed a new we needed we needed
conference we needed a new approach
focused on raising economic growth
because that is the only real way to
deliver opportunities to deliver higher
wages to deliver more jobs and crucially
to deliver that Revenue to fund our
precious public services and it is the
best and only way of achieving long-term
fiscal sustainability
because it is only by raising economic
growth that we will spread opportunity
and prosperity to every corner of our
country with economic growth everybody
benefits and I mean everybody
while we all believe in growth we as
conservatives also believe that it is an
important principle that people should
keep more of the money they earn I don't
need to tell you that
I don't need to tell you that
I know I don't need to tell you that
that isn't radical that isn't
irresponsible it is a deeply held belief
that we all share as conservatives we
were faced with a 70-year high tax
burden we were confronted with low
growth and the path we were on was
clearly unsustainable
so that's why we are cutting taxes for
working people that's why we will
reverse the National Insurance hike on
the 6th of November and that's why we
will bring forward the 1p cut to the
basic rate of income tax by one year
that's why that's why that's why we will
take 200 000 people out of paying stamp
Duty altogether taken together this is
what our support will do for all our
people
thanks to our energy intervention a
typical person in a semi-detached
property will save 1 150 pounds on their
energy bills this winter on top of the
400 pounds discount and if they are
earning an average salary they will
benefit from an additional tax cut of
around 400 pounds that is almost a 2 000
pound saving this year alone
but I can be frank I know the plan put
forward only 10 years days ago has
caused a little turbulence I get it I
get it
uh we are listening and have listened
and now I want to focus on delivering
the major parts of our growth package
because with energy bills skyrocketing a
painful coveted aftermath war on our
continent as 70-year High tax burden
slowing Global growth rates and
glacially slow infrastructure delivery
we couldn't simply do nothing
we can't sit idly by what Britain needs
more than ever is economic growth and
the government wholly committed to
economic growth that is why we will
Forge a new economic deal for Britain
but by an ironclad commitment to fiscal
discipline more businesses
more businesses more jobs higher paid
more money for public services because
we cannot have a strong NHS without a
strong economy we can't have good
schools without a strong economy we
cannot fund our Armed Forces without a
strong economy so growing our economy
should be our Central and guiding
mission
with this plan we are aiming for two and
a half percent annual Trend growth we've
done it before and we can do it again
and even in the face
and even in the face of extreme
volatility in global markets with major
currencies wrestling and incredibly
strong US dollar and longer term Trends
from demographic change to climate
change we will show that our plan is
sound
that it is credible and that it will
increase growth that is our pledge to
the people of this country
however however conference there is an
immediate challenge facing not just our
country not just our people but the
whole of Europe
the high cost of energy driven by
Putin's barbaric invasion of Ukraine
cast your mind back just four weeks ago
we had dire warnings of extreme Energy
prices to come
Corner shops to heavy industry predicted
unprecedented disruption business groups
feared mass unemployment entire
livelihoods were on the line
make no mistake this was a very real
Prospect for our country
So within 48 Hours of taking office we
announced one of the most significant
interventions ever conceived by the
British state
annual energy bills of up to six
thousand five hundred pounds from next
year were stirring staring Us in the
face everybody was worried now we are
holding down the price at an average of
2 500 pounds not just this winter like
the labor party promised but next winter
too two years of significant taxpayer
support to protect our people because
this government
because of this government
will always be on the side of those who
need help the most
for our businesses too conference help
is on its way a local pub could save 3
100 pounds a month cutting their bills
by 40 and we've also frozen alcohol Duty
make no mistake this is a Monumental
support package to protect millions of
families and businesses from devastating
price hikes Unleashed by Vladimir Putin
there is no doubt that this is a
substantial intervention
but we had no choice doing something was
simply not an option we couldn't just
cross our fingers and hope for the best
the price of inaction would have been
far greater than the cost of the scheme
we will deal with the short-term shocks
caused by Putin but we must also go for
growth to ensure we are much more
self-sufficient we will tackle the
mistakes of the past to ensure the UK
can never again be blackmailed by people
such as Putin and his life
foreign
hit our Shores we were right to
intervene to protect lives and
livelihoods and I can say in all
sincerity that we went into that crisis
in a much better position because of the
action we have taken over the last
decade
because of successive conservative
governments the UK now has the second
lowest debt to GDP ratio in the G7 and
throughout this urgent Endeavor of ours
to protect Britain from high energy
costs and in response to the urgent need
to grow our economy we have taken the
appropriate action
our entire approach will be underpinned
by a strong institutional framework
which enhances growth in our country
including our Independent Bank of
England and office for Budget
responsibility we will have a strong
fiscal anchor with debt falling as a
percentage a proportion of GDP over the
medium term that is the conservative way
but
but today we Face new challenges and in
addressing those challenges we will act
in a fiscally sustainable and
responsible way that is why shortly we
will publish our medium-term fiscal plan
setting out our approach more fully it
will set out how we plan to get debt
falling as a percentage of GDP over the
medium term and I have asked the obr to
publish a full economic and fiscal
forecast alongside our medium-term
fiscal plan there is no path to higher
sustainable growth without fiscal
responsibility conservatives have always
known this and we know it still
and it is because we are conservatives
that we remain absolutely committed to
being serious custodians of the public
purse this is what defines us and
separates us from the labor party
but conference
to grow the economy we really do need to
do things differently we know that it is
our towns and cities which Drive much of
our economic growth today business
investment skills Science and Technology
infrastructure housing energy Supply
strong financial services these are the
key ingredients for higher economic
growth and well-funded public services I
had the great privilege of being
business secretary for nearly two years
I visited every corner of this country I
saw the creativity the drive the
entrepreneurial Spirit we have to
celebrate our entrepreneurs our business
people our job creators people who are
taking risks but I also saw where
governments got in the way of progress
my job now is to free that potential
this starts with investment zones we
will Empower local areas to do things
differently just as here in Birmingham
we will liberalize planning rules
release land and accelerating
development we will cut taxes for
businesses in those zones we will
accelerate tax reliefs for new
structures and for new buildings we will
provide relief on investments on plant
and Machinery we will lower taxes which
stop businesses hiring and Skilling up
their Workforce
that is unprecedented set of incentives
for business to invest to create jobs to
build right across our country and it
will start right now
conference we will get Britain moving
but
but too often too often regulation holds
business and Britain back
stifling red tape puts up too many
barriers for entrepreneurs looking to
scale up there are too many rules for
small business owners who want to take
on an apprentice there are too many
burdens on our finance sector stopping
it from investing in key projects and
when Britain's innovators job creators
entrepreneurs and Risk Takers are held
back so is Britain that is why we will
review replace or repeal retained EU law
holding our country back
we will all say we will also speed up
the delivery of infrastructure and
promote house building to create a true
homeowning shareholding democracy
unapologetically and emphatically we
will get out of the way to get Britain
building and on its feet
over the coming days and weeks we will
Forge ahead and break down the barriers
that have held our country back for too
long on Child Care agriculture
immigration planning energy Broadband
Business Financial Services
sensible economic reforms to produce
more of the products and services we
need to drive down costs to create jobs
and to generate to generate higher pay
and product productivity
and when it comes to those who would
hold us back
we will act pernicious strike action
disrupts the lives of British people and
slows down our economy it stops children
going to school it stops parents from
going to work and it stops people from
getting the vital care that they need
action which slows down our economy
cannot be the policy of any serious any
serious party serious about growth and a
party which is not serious about growth
can never be considered fit for office
so we will introduce important reforms
to stop strike action from derailing our
daily lives reform to get Britain moving
conference I am unashamedly a
pro-business conservative
you know that the interests of business
and hard-working families are not in
conflict they are aligned when
businesses Thrive they create more jobs
they raise wages and they contribute
more for our Public Services rather than
bashing business we are backing it that
is why we need to make our tax
that is why we need to make our tax
system simpler more competitive and
pro-growth
so we will reverse the plans increase in
corporation tax
insuring ensuring we have the lowest
rate in the G20 this will plow almost 19
billion pounds a year back into the
economy that's 19 billion pounds for
businesses to reinvest to create jobs
and raise wages we will reverse the
reforms to ir35 that have added
unnecessary unnecessary complexity
unnecessary complexity and cost for so
many businesses we will maintain the one
million pound annual investment
allowance giving 100 tax relief on
investments in plants and machinery
for over a decade the conservative party
has stood up for working people in this
country since 2010 we have delivered the
lowest unemployment since the 1970s a
million new businesses more than
doubling the tax-free personal allowance
we've taken two million of the lowest
paid out of paying tax altogether the
national living wage boosting the pay
packets of the lowest paid fuel Duty
Frozen for 12 years the one thousand
pound uplift in Universal Credit making
sure work always pays these are great
achievements conservative achievements
and let us not forget when this party
came into government we were met with
the full force of Labor's economic
incompetence no money left taxes raised
record unemployment we reversed that
story of national decline but even after
three election defeats they still
haven't learned their lesson the labor
party would have you believe that every
penny you earn should go straight into
the government's coffers the labor party
believed that they know how to spend
your money better than you do the labor
party believe that they can tax their
way to growth
we don't believe that
we believe in low tax high growth and
fiscal discipline we are conservatives
and that conference is what our growth
plan delivers last week we saw a labor
party with the same old ideas
renationalization empty slogans no plan
for growth but we as conservatives
believe in Britain we love this country
our patriotism isn't something that we
turn on and off and negotiate like the
labor party it goes to the core of what
it is to be a conservative it is an
unyielding quality yes we have
challenges to face but our plan will
take this country forward we will get
Britain moving we will deliver lower
taxes for you and your family and we
will grow our economy I know we can
achieve that goal with grit with drive
and with determination we can meet the
challenges of this new era thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
speech
well there you go
quasi-ponting the chancellor delivering
his speech to Conservative Party
Conference in Birmingham to Applause
from the hall hey there was a nod to the
u-turn at the beginning of the speech
what a day he said it's been tough no
more distractions um but at the same
time this was a speech where he really
lent into the need for economic growth
and it's saying that the government you
just go forward with its plan Sam what
did you make of it
it was not a speech with any great
announcement there was something new
that we haven't heard it was a bit like
a kind of greatest hits of what we've
heard in the Commons and the newspaper
articles sometimes what leaders um
chance of speech is there is a second
biggest moment of uh a party conference
and you would expect either there to be
language or a new policy or just
something that moves on the political
debate um there wasn't much sign of that
in this and there was one incredibly
striking thing about this speech which
was yes he acknowledged that today he
has chance I had to do something
incredibly difficult and junk amongst
the most high profile
um uh policies 45p tax rate that he has
done since becoming Chancellor and there
was a nod to that at the beginning and
he did it in a way that was completely
felt quite sensible
but then on this day we're quite clearly
conservative MPS are sore you know this
U-turn was forced on them by an alliance
of people from Michael Gove downwards
Grant chats plenty of them going public
even more behind the scenes then in the
speech that he gives the hall crazy
spanked quite a lot of the speech
kicking them what do I mean by that he
kept going on about the failures of
recent governments now who are those
recent governments well it's Boris
Johnson's government it's Rishi sunaka's
Chancellor he talked about slow manage
decline well that's a direct attack on
the people that were sitting in the
chair that he sits in today
so how's that going to calm nerds how's
that going to win people over it took
three times about the highest tax burden
since the 1970s yes that's true yes
there's trust stands for something else
but there is a a wounded unhappy
conservative party that today has shown
it is willing to flex its muscles if
they don't like the direction that Liz
trust and quasi quality are taking the
government into State and basically
quasi quatting stood up there for 20
minutes and rub salt in the wind I
forgot two audiences here that we were
talking about before that politicians it
seems from your analysis might be
feeling a bit more bruised potentially
after that speech or at least some of
her Boris Johnson originalize how about
the other audience that we're talking
about near the markets he was talking a
bit about physical responsibility wasn't
he about economic growth do you think
there's much reassuring in the speech
for that audience well away yeah so so
for that audience whereas Sam was saying
you know I remember kind of previous
conference speeches chancellors
conference speeches particularly under
George Osborne where he would always
kind of arrive with a policy you know
you would actually move the dial and
things would feel like they were kind of
starting to change here like
paradoxically actually perhaps what he
was aiming for was not to move the dial
at all you know just to kind of clamp
down to calm things down and you know I
basically did that I mean it was pretty
unremarkable as these speeches go to be
honest with you I mean
Lots about as Sam was saying about
growth I mean
can't think of any politician who
doesn't like growth but you know it's
good that the conservative party is is
embracing that that logical truth
um reversing the story of national
decline after the labor party a lot of
the kind of you know tried and tested
hits that you tend to hear at Party
Conference biggest cheer that I could
detect was about reviewing replacing or
repealing EU laws so back to brexit so
to some extent Sam was saying it's a bit
of a greatest hits thing but a quite
kind of tentative one and you know if
you're looking at kind of mood music
and there's a slightly slightly downbeat
mood as they go but it wasn't it I mean
it was quite muted I thought to be
honest I mean you know look we've been
to you've seen many of these features on
TV before in the hall or whatever on TV
at Party Conference I felt that the
atmosphere was quite muted in that yeah
I mean it's a bit of a bruised
conference right everyone woke up to you
know 12 20 in the morning suggestions of
a tax U-turn that arrived uh in
everybody's inboxes and on their social
media feeds at 7 20 in the morning and
that's uncomfortable for a political
party right and you watch the hall the
Applause on the way in was quite brief
the Applause on the way out was quite
pleasing we we weren't talking kind of
Mega reception there was there was a
great deal I I thought for the audience
to sort of massively you know massively
get get to grips with but the other
reason I think things are quite muted
um is that there are lots of elephants
in the room there's an awful lot we
don't know such as how is all the fiscal
responsibility how is all the you know
managing to stay within your budget has
any of that going to happen huge
decisions we're waiting for from this
Chancellor no idea no idea of any more
detail from him after today another
elephant in the room I thought as far as
I can tell one of the biggest political
challenges that we're going to be
talking about the next 18 months is the
consequence of higher interest rates and
high borrowing levels cheaper mortgage
is disappearing people are gonna have to
pay hundreds of pounds or keep going on
about this but it's really important to
get to hold on to their houses to hold
on to their properties uh from higher
mortgage payments not a word about that
either and so you've got all of these
big questions these big sort of in
ponderables not addressed in the hall
yes he ticked all the boxes that a
chance to speech would normally take yes
he bashed the opposition yes he talks in
Praise of Grace but there was a just so
much unaddressed so you were sort of
left wondering what the what what was
the big Point what what was the thing he
hoped to take away us all to take away
from that he did I mean well yeah the
one thing he wanted to talk about was
energy and I think that's the kind of
the interesting thing is is you
potentially see a real re-emphasis on
the fact that the energy policy like you
were saying beforehand Sam was wasn't as
popular and of all the bits of the many
budget that's the most popular bit
um but yeah it was it was it but on the
energy it's a really interesting
question about political right away at
this conference they are desperate
desperate to try and get some political
credit for the 160 billion pounds they
spent two weeks ago on the two it's the
energy fine it's difficult it's been
crowded out obviously big events have
been going on but one of the other
reasons it's so difficult to get credit
for that energy policy is because the
rate at which the unit rate or which
energy price has been fixed is twice
what it was last year so people are
still hurting from energy price
increases so you will get some credit
for protecting what you stopped
happening but it's harder to get credit
when it's still causing people playing
particularly when people are just
getting those announcements right now
right they're just learning at the
moment about how much their bill is
going to go I should say Sophie markets
did not crash
to be honest with you but let's not put
it down to that uh guilt rates didn't
move all that much I mean the scheme was
success such things yeah they might be
quite happy I remember doing this
analysis with you after the budget so
that certainly this doesn't look like a
bit better picture picture and thank you
both very much to indeed for your
analysis icon weather at sanco it's
talking us through that confidence
speech by the chancellor quantity